[Music]
morning
breakfast and coffee come boy
i just wanted to explain why gabby's
poor nose has a plaster on it
she recently had an operation on a nurse
for something what was it for a septum
a septum which means
what do you mean what is it what
happened
how they did the operation so they have
to take your nose
off like that what do you mean off so
they have to
cut it over there and pull it back and
then fix the
way and then put it back oh my god
okay but it looks good this is like a
week ago and you are
better now yes you're good
yeah just sucks because i've been stuck
inside recovering and now i'm finally
feeling better but now
it's been raining for so long and i
thought that i was going to be able to
do something fun
okay so what you're saying is you can't
do something fun when it's raining
like it's all wet and cold
okay challenge accepted
[Music]
before starting to brainstorm fun [ __ ]
to do when it's raining
i'd just like to tell you that this
video is sponsored by my close friends
at epidemic sound
epidemic is the sound of music library
wait let me check back epidemic in my
opinion
is the greatest sound and music library
on the internet
but more on them later back to the video
[Music]
okay i've made a list of some pretty
good ideas i think it's gonna be a good
day
okay baby i'm just gonna head out for a
bit get warm
put on your weighties i'll see you in an
hour
okay so first on the list is to recreate
the iconic scene from the notebook
where ali confronts noah about the fact
that he didn't write her
writing but then it turns out that noah
actually
didn't just write one letter but wrote
365 letters
and then they make up and kiss and
whatever and in order to
recreate this bit i'm gonna need a bunch
of props for my studio as well as
i need to waterproof my camera
before we get going there's a few people
i want you to meet
this is rain what do you do here i get
[ __ ] done this is jared
oh hey guys i'm a brand creative at joe
phones what does that mean great
meaningful and cool [ __ ]
there you go this is chris hi dan what
are you doing here
i'm the bean counter what does that mean
it means i look after the money
sounds hectic
meet jason how's it going what do you do
so i'm a sound designer and a school
composer it means that i do a whole
bunch of sound design and write music
for movies
what are you working on right now this
is a one hour school for a new discovery
show
sounds pretty cool
[Music]
meet liam hello what do you do i
coordinate the first production side of
every project
i sound boring meet
reader hi and luke hi what do you do
i edit what do you do and because
rita and luke are new they need to be
initiated
which means they're just about to get
dressed in these ridiculous puffy suits
and they're going to drop in
on the half pipe it's hilarious don't
ask it's traditionally at joe forms
you guys still content to this
[Music]
okay and three
two one
how do you feel ah
okay you are officially part of the joe
team
welcome to the team
i just realized i haven't updated you in
forever on what's happening here
and welcome to the inner workings of joe
phones which is a film production house
that i'm busy building
you just made some of the team but there
are 11 of us that work here and we plan
on just growing bigger and bigger
we've just finished the brand idea which
i'm super stoked
are we busy working on a whole bunch of
really rad meaningful projects
like shows for the discovery channels
discovery plus we're also
busy workshopping my first feature film
that i'll be directing early next year
and then we're also working on some
other tv ads and whatnot
however we still have a long long way to
go before launching this company
efficiently i've just been speaking to
you about it on youtube
but technically we're not live yet okay
let's get back to setting up this
recreation shot of the notebook
in order to recreate the scene i'm gonna
need two sets of rode lapel microphones
and an external sound recorder a zoom h6
one clapper board
one medium to long lens this 24 to 105 l
series lens will do the trick
one 4k camera this is a canon 1dx mod 2.
we will waterproof the camera
and the sound equipment with this rain
cover back and then additional props and
wardrobe we'll need
this blue dress like ali was wearing as
well as her whole necklace
and nose wardrobe which is just this
white shirt as well as a
boat with two oars
and lastly i'll need liam to help me
shoot
you ready ready let's go
where we going we are now going to
go and recreate a scene from your
favorite movie
then outfit yeah the final scene where
it's raining
they're nervous why
we're gonna do it legit i got us a boat
and everything and we're gonna go down
to the big tidal pool
and lastly i got you exactly what ali
was wearing
why wasn't she in a jersey i'm gonna be
rocking out like nowhere
okay time to get dressed
hey ellie i know
let's go
don't want to see what's happening to me
so warm now enjoy the shower a little
bit more because we're about to go back
out there
just want to show you that there's fun
things to do in the rain next on the
awesome [ __ ] to do while it's raining
list
is park surfing what's park saving
you'll see
[Music]
this is [ __ ] i have no idea where that
water's from
oh no time to do the third thing on the
list
[Music]
we are now doing number three on the
list which is
supposed to be hot tub in the rain the
rain has stopped but it's still
[ __ ] cold okay it comes this is hot
tubbing in winter this is hot
in winter and i can make it rain i can
make it rain should i make it rain i'm
coming now
what's happening in the rain
baby i'll see you next hour bye baby see
you now
gabs had to leave to do some family
stuff which means we won't have enough
time to do
number four and five on the list number
four being pokey
which is south africa's coziest
traditional dish we just won't have
enough time it takes a long time and
it's a
mission not to say that number five is
in a mission which is to turn the
bedroom
into a theater but i think that gaby
will appreciate this most as well as i
really want to show her the notebook
recreation scene
that's hilarious time to turn our
bedroom
into a cinema
i have a projector here with a projector
screen that's going to be playing
our recreation of the notebook as well
as the entire movie i got us a popcorn
machine
i took all the fluffy pillows from
around the house and put them on the bed
for
maximum comfort before i surprise gabs
with the cinema room
and we watch back the recreation scene
of the notebook i just want to tell you
more about my good friends and sponsors
of this video epidemic has just extended
their sound library to include more than
90 000
high quality sound effects they also
made it super easy for me to save time
searching and finding sound effects by
improving the tagging and categorization
both their product and catalog of tracks
and sound effects is built with you
a filmmaker in mind so that you can
focus on what you do best
so if you support me go over and support
them too because they are just
so great so yeah if you want to make
your videos better by adding great sound
and music
head over to the link in the description
and get a 30 day free trial okay
let's go surprise gaps watch me your
hand
okay okay down the stairs
okay down there down there
smells good what does it smell like
salty
salty come forward backwards
and take your blindfold off
this is so cool
what are we watching the scene that we
made
okay i'm just going to turn the lights
off and then it's the moment of truth
this is like mega home home video
[Music]
nowhere
why didn't you ride me why
it wasn't over for me i waited for you
for seven years
and now it's too late i wrote you 365
letters
i wrote you every day for a year you
wrote to me
yes it wasn't over for me
it still isn't over
[Music]
oh sorry sorry okay
[Laughter]
i'm going to sign this vlog out now
before we watch the notebook for the
278th time hopefully we proved that you
can't have fun
on a rainy day yes why did you take so
long to reply
it outside on a rainy day so what do you
mean so the cinema is not fair
no it's always an option for a rainy day
okay i worked really hard i don't know
if this was always an option
i hope not this is a lot of work it took
me forever
okay anyways don't forget to like and
subscribe
we work really hard on these videos and
i hope that you enjoy them other than
that don't forget
your awesome brew and we'll see you next
week
you